Pewds: Oh hey PJ! *Zooms in on PJ's face*
PJ: Hey Felix! How's it going?
Pewds: Glad you could it make it once again.
PJ: Yeah, I know it was a quite a trip, but I made it.
Pewds: Last time...
I lost.
Past Pewds: F*ck this game!
Past PJ: Why the f*ck me?! YOU RECOMMENDED THIS!!!
Pewds: ...game. Stupid... *Poods wuz triggered*
PJ: You recommended...
Present pJ: Correct
Poods: But I got a new challenge for you PJ!
PJ: WHOOOAH!!! *shakes*
Pewds: Ohohoho!!! *more shakes*
--wikiHow-- *oHnOoOoO*
Pewds: What do you know about wikiHow?
PJ: I spent hours studying wikiHow.
Pewds: Is this how you're so good at fet-ish? *laughs*
PJ: Just I have for things. Yes. This is how I accomplish everything in life.
Pewds: Okay. So we're... we get the picture from wikiHow article.
But we have to guess...
PJ: WHOA! ~(⊕⌢⊕)~
*Poods questions his choice of freindship*
PJ: Sorry...  ᕙ(⇀‸↼‶)ᕗ
Pewds: I appreciate that...(oh really)
PJ: Okay, I'm just trying to...
I'm just trying to be enthusiastic, really. (REALLY)
Pewds: No.
PJ: It's hard to get enthusiastic over...
...over this (tru)
Pewds: Okay, we'll guess the title (O.O)
Gappa: But wait! There is a twist ⊂•⊃_⊂•⊃
The loser has to highlight their hair. (with a highlighter)
*both gasp* MAH GAWD LOOK AT PJ's FASE
PJ: That's not actually too bad then so ┐(‘～`)┌
Pewds: It's actually not that bad. I could do that (oh really)
Pewds: You're bald so
PJ: Ho. ●︿●
PJ: Woah, didn't need see that!
Pewds: Go!
PJ: Well, this is clearly
"How to Walk From A to B"
Pewds: Wait. I'm sorry. I forgot to tell you
youu
Pewds: you could actually...
PJ: Oh there's a choice? (OMG)
Pewds: Yeah. How to get a lesbian
PJ: THAT WOULD HAVE HELPED ಠ益ಠ
Okay
What the fuck?
PJ: This isn't any of these things (PJ is smart)
Pewds: Oh
PJ: Or is it? *exaggerated zoom-in*
OH
MAH
GAWSH
PJ: Ah okay I'm gonna
I'm just gonna guess because WHAT THE FUCK is this game?
What is this?
Pewds: WHAT!?*TRIGGERED PEWDS*
PJ: woh!
Pewds: THAT WAS RIGHT?!!?!?!?!? (Pewds isn't amused)
PJ: But that didn't make any sense
Can we play a game that makes sense?
Pewds: Shut up (bich)
Pewds: Don't- I know this one
PJ: Okay this is yours
"How To Prevent Identity Theft"
PJ: *Sarcastically* By mailing a fish to someone...
(seems legit okay)
Pewds: "How To Catch a Cheating Girlfriend"
"By mailing a fish to someone" *laughs*
"How To Find A Husband When The Women....
...Outnumber the Men in The Country?" (poods is confused)
"How To Choose A Rigorous College Schedule
For Your First..."
I think this one
**WRONG**
Pewds: NO!
PJ: Nopeh
PJ: NNNNNOPEH
Pewds: NOOOOOO!!!
Pewds: NOOOOOO!! (◕︵◕)
NNNOPE!
Pewds: Gappa please?!?!?! *laughs* (PAPA GAPPA!)
PJ: That was "How To Prod-
Prevent Identity Theft"
Pewds: *whispers* I'm so upset...
PJ: "How to Choose a puppy."
Awwwww (づ｡◕‿‿◕｡)づ
"How to Succeed In A Relationship With The Perfect Girl." ((SPOILER ALERT: this is the correct answer))
Pewds: Uhmm?...Yeah...
PJ: How..*laughs*
Pewds: ...That seems about right. *laugh*
PJ: Yeah this seems very...
Uh... very.. this seems like a...
...very well balanced relationship.
I'm seeing here.
"How to keep dogs off lawn"
*Both laugh*
PJ: "How to make lemonade when life gives you lemons"
Oh, I don't know, mhan.
Pewds: How is this harder than the fucking game I had?
PJ: Yeah, what is this?
Alright, I'm just gonna go with this, 'cause it seems the most...
It doesen't seem logical, but I'm gonna...
*Correct*
WHOOOOOAAAA!!
AYO!
Pewds: How do you always get it right? *poods is more confused*
PJ: Like I said, I been studying wikiHow for a while now, and, yeah, just...
Pewds: You fucking nerd.
PJ: Yeah, well...
Pewds: Ohhhh.
PJ: Whoooa.
PJ: Don't mess with these dudes
Pewds: Ohhhhhh...
Wow
PJ: These dudes will bash you up
Pewds: That guy looks cool...*laughs*   ToTALLY AwEsomE
"How to...
"...tell if you genuinely like someone".
Pewds: Hwmmmmm
PJ: No.
Pewds: "How to ask a girl for a dance".
PJ: With a baseball bat
*Sounds like CinnamonToastKen* HEY GIRL!
Pewds: *Aweful Italian accent* HEY GIRL YOU WANNA GO FOR A DANCE?
PJ: *1960s Old Black Man?* YOU WANNA DANCE WITH ME? *OH YES PJ I WOULD LIKE 2 DNCE WITH YOU*
Pewds: I got a barret you better dance-
Pewds: How to induce Nightmares
PJ: I mean Yeah- This is pretty nightmare-
Pewds: HOW TO BE A PUNK (that was easy)
*"CORRECT" sound fx*
Pewds: SLAMMIN
PJ: Well that was pretty- fuckin' easy *laugh* (damn right)
Pewds: How to have snakes as your haircut *laughs*
PJ: He's got a lot of pewdiepies on his head ✌.ʕʘ‿ʘʔ.✌
PJ: Cause felix-  Pewds: OHH! Because im a shnake *TRIGGERED*
PJ: Cause felix is a snek  Pewds: Fuk you
PJ: How to visit- I thought it said lasagna beach
Pewds: *snicker*
PJ: Laguna Beach Calf- California
PJ: How to catch a cheating Girlfriend
PJ: what's he thinking?- What's in his mind?
*HUSH MY CHILD*
Both: Uhhhh   Pewds: this might be my point! My point. PJ: my point   Bulletball:my point
PJ: This is rediculous -How to dissapear like a ninja..*wrong* Nope
Pewds: OH YEAH, YOU DIDN'T DO IT!!
Pewds: Fuck You!
PJ: well how- Well what's this felix? huh?
PJ: if you're so good at wiki how
PJ: cmon felix - Hit us up- What is this?
Pewds: i dont-   PJ: face flying off your b- What is this?   Pewds: HOW TO BE A PUNK! *totally*
PJ: Yeah- clearly.
*Both laugh*
Pewds: How to pick up girls in high schoollllllll-No.
Pewds: How to have a Successful open source project
Pewds: I imagine that's what that feels like
PJ: this does scream open source to me
Pewds: How to have fun without friends, Seems like the only one
PJ: I mean-   Pewds: but it still doesn't fit for-
PJ: Hey you wouldn't even need to read that article!
*poods is sad he got burned*
Pewds: *triggered* WELL HOW ABOUT I SELECT THAT ONE THEN!!!
Pewds: *GASP* THATZ RIGHT! PJ: OOHHH
Pewds: fuk you- well why am I cheering, I'm not winning*hehe*
PJ: are you not? Pewds: no, you have one up to me PJ: oh great thats good
PJ: well this is probably Pewds: I really wanna find this article
PJ: this is probably a type of pornography you know
PJ: its not one I'd wanna read-
Pewds: well your the one who knows all of the fe-tishes
*Giggles* Pewds: *IKR* PJ: yep.
PJ: again it's not aNY OF THESE- uh.. How to talk to girls..
PJ: how to- Fuck it. *wrong*
PJ:Nope. Pewds: *yES*  PJ: how to dissapear like a ninja
Pewds:*whispers* fuk ye
Pewds: nah this is ez- this is easy lemme tell ya PJ: okay, okay
Pewds: How to love your girlfriend- *Wrong*
Pewds: SHET
PJ: it was how to make lemonade when life gives you lemons! OBVIOUSLY *because duh*
Pewds: DAMNITT
PJ: damnit felix
Pewds: fuk PJ: fuk
PJ: uh how to-  Jesus christ-
Pewds: how to Kill yourself with cream- PJ: how to rip your throat out in one ez movement
PJ: How to decide if you should become a stipper
*Giggle*
PJ:how to catch a cheating Girlfriend
PJ: how to act like "one of the guys"
PJ: how to clear up a stuffy nose
Pewds: I think its cheating girlfriend, it must be cheating- dAMNIT
PJ: *( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*  Pewds: that one was so obvious PJ: mah point!
Pewds: uhhhh     PJ: How to enjoy phone sex
Pewds:*giggle* ooh
PJ: he's enjoying himself ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Pewds: wat is "Joie De Vivre"???  *Noice dance PJ*
PJ: *disbelif* you don't- what you don't know??
PJ: *this guyy* Pewds: ur telling me you know? PJ: This guy doesnt know what *pause*
PJ: joy dev-
Pewds: WHAT IS IT PJ
PJ: oh man it would blow your mind Pewds: CMON TELL ME
PJ: it would *BOOM*
*click* *right*
Pewds: I did know all along  ( its actually " enjoyment of life" )
PJ: you new all along Pewds: Mah point! *laugh*
PJ: his point! *my point*
Pewds: OOH ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) PJ:WOAH i got the sexi onee~
Pewds: i need to find this one ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
PJ: How to Act silly with your Boyfriend
Pewds:*giggle* PJ: how to find a husband When the women out number the men in your Country..
PJ: how to show your husband that you love him
PJ: how to turn a girl on *TITLE*  Both: ooh  Pewds: tricky tricky
PJ: i think silly- I- *wrong* I think acting silly
PJ: no. *T_T*
Pewds: how to dream of pewdiepie! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) PJ: how to brofist- yeah okay
PJ: you got it
PJ: run away from home
PJ: yeah!
PJ: im running away :D!! * dont leave pls*
Pewds: I think thats it!
PJ: yeah, go for it, Why not?
PJ: dont even read the other one
PJ: oh you might need to read that article felix *giggle*
*not fine, much sad*
Pewds: how tooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
Pewds: rUN AWAY FROM HOME!!
Pewds: OH!
PJ: this is bullsh- Pewds: What the fuck are these pictures? PJ: how to-
PJ: fuckin get possesed by a ghost- Pewds: mam when i grow up *never*
Pewds:i wanna draw pictures from wiki how *giggles* (please no)
PJ: how to survive domestic violence
PJ: how to have Jehovah witnesses go away
Pewds: they are a pain in the ass when they come from your belly *ikr*
PJ: how to talk dirty in bed ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
PJ: how to survive a coyote attack
Pewds: I've always wondered if using your belly ghost would work on a coyote attack or not
PJ: yeah no it doesnt- trust me. (I'VE TRIED IT. IT WORKS!)
PJ: oh I dont know
Pewds: what is he doing? think about the situation.      PJ: he is-
Pewds: hey PJ~
PJ: why is he-  Pewds: what is this?
PJ: why is he partly see through as well
PJ: you can see the rocks
PJ: that he's not even sitting on
Pewds: oh yeah your right *giggle*
PJ: this is an error in the drawing   Pewds: no.
PJ: i dunno, maybe domestic violence?? but..
*Right* PJ: yeah fuk it
PJ: YES- MY POINT- SLAMMIN!! ✌.ʕʘ‿ʘʔ.✌
PJ: so what? she's saying sex and he's like-O.O Pewds:She seems a bit forward *giggle*
PJ: yeah... S3X
Pewds: how to know if your Girlfriend wants to have sex with you
Pewds: well if she says *giggle* PJ: I think it might be
PJ: how to get rid of an unwanted erection y'know? Pewds: yey
PJ: i've just got a really good feeling about this unwanted erection*( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*
Pewds:  I've got a good feeling to! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
PJ: i've never felt this good about an unwanted erection
Pewds: anytime i want to get rid of my erection i just ask a girl to yell "sex!" at me (TRUTH)
PJ: okay- yeah- whatever
Pewds: that got weird PJ: that did get weird
Pewds: yyYEESS
PJ: I mean that's not- you can't really
Pewds: HOW WOULD I POSSIBLY KNOW- THANK YOU WIKI HOW ARTICLE FOR ILLISTRATING SO WELL- i spit on the screen..
Pewds: thank you
Pewds: we're gonna have to do- whoever loses next one
Pewds: is fucking out- jesus christ
PJ: it's because you lost count
Pewds: you got this PJ!
Pewds: i did not lost count
Pewds: i did not.
PJ: I got this. I got this
PJ: what's she doing- shes smiling. Pewds: how to feed a snake- that's it that's it PJ! you got this!
PJ: my DESTINY is calling me! *OMG*
Pewds: how to increase your ejac*giggle*ulation
PJ: waait waat
PJ:how to be pretty, how to play with a pet
PJ: well there's not pets involved
PJ: there is no ejaculate involved.
PJ:and there is no *pewds* invloved.. so... by process of ilimination, I'm gonna guess it's how to be pretty
Pewds: if you think thats pretty, i mean, go right ahead
PJ: Dude. The human form IS pretty. *thx*
*100%*
PJ: YES! SLAMMIN!! ✌.ʕʘ‿ʘʔ.✌
Pewds: fuk you
Pewds: get outta the way. PJ: Droppin some- WOAHH, that's pretty.. *both giggle*
Pewds: that's the REAL how to be pretty. PJ: yeahh
Pewds: How to dress up like a hillbilly
Pewds: HOW TO LOSE YOUR VIRGINITY WITHOUT-PAIN (girls)  I hope that's not what it looks like *noice dance PJ*
Pewds: how to play wink murder *PJ winks*
Pewds: how to be comfortable in ur own skin *totally*    *wrong..*
Pewds: oh no... PJ: YEP! it was clearly how to dress up like a hillbilly! *IKR JUST LOOK AT THOSE SHORTS*
PJ: fELIX! You know what that means!!
PJ: gubble! pewds: no!
PJ:Gubble why- Pewds: GUBBLE PLZ
PJ: tELL ME WHAT I WANT TO HEAR
The gansta Gubble: By the power Invested in me- I deem that PJ is the winner!1! :D
Pewds: Fak PJ: THX GUBBLE!
Pewds: dAMNIT!
PJ: Oh man, Me and gubble!
PJ: we- we should probably go out for a drink sometime y'know! ;))
PJ: thank you- Oh wow!
Pewds: AWE SHET  GUBBLE CMON * Pj giggles*   ( gubble looks so scared oml )
Pewds: gawd damnit
Pewds: do I really have to gubble? :C
PJ: okay what color do you want- i mean, blue was a massive failure ( lol wow pj sick burn broski)
PJ: is there really any other color that you- Pewds: WHATS THAT???!
PJ: wat Pewds: whats that? PJ: is there any other color- you got a preferece  for *gubble secretly eating poods' ear*
PJ: does gubble have a preferece?? *gubble says pink*
Pewds: he said uhh pink!
PJ: pink!  oh I get lil gloves!
Pewds: wat?! PJ:oh- wat, okay.
PJ: felix, bend over pls~( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
PJ: never done this before *mhm*
*sexy ;) *
PJ: you're like a sexy anime school girl * preach!! he always has tbh *
Pewds: you dunno how to do highlights??
Pewds: oh i know how to *hand motion* I mean Pft!
Pewds: not that I would know * so manly*
Pewds: nneheneh wOAH!
Pewds: wHAT DID YOU JUST DO??
PJ: I'm trying to apply- I think we need water y'know?
PJ: ooooh
PJ: alright (✿◠‿◠)
PJ: oh that makes sense.
Pewds: hey could you do like a rainbow?? *fabulous fam*
PJ: i could try. ( atleast PJ makes an effort (▰˘◡˘▰) )
PJ: i mean- Pewds: that'd be cool. PJ: yeaaah
Pewds: * 2 lil girls* this is us right now PJ. * I see the resemblence*
*giggles*
PJ: OH y'know everyone's gonna say your copying markiplier ( more like mini ladd with that pink hair)
PJ: with the uh red hair! (it's pink tho)
Pewds: No i got it ferst!
Pewds: MARK.
PJ: well this isn't like.. Pewds: it's not mah color!!?
PJ: no i mean i think it looks good, but..
PJ: well I think if you wanna go rainbow.. * pewds looks fabb*
PJ: were gonna need some red.. aswell..
Pewds: okay, I can do red ( now its mrkiplir)
PJ: oh well thats not- OHH- well thats MUCH more effective!
Pewds: I'm gonna look gr8!
Pewds: you're gonna be super- so super jealous
PJ: yeah I think we're nearly just about done here.
PJ: I just wanna be sure- Pewds: HOW MUCH ARE YOU PUTTING IN??
PJ: well you said you wanted a lot right? Pewds: No I DID NOT  SAY THAT! WTF? PJ: oh okay. (my bad)
PJ: Uh yeah, that's pretty uh- Pewds: AUGH IT FEELS  WEIRD (⊙︿⊙✿)
PJ: yeah. I think that looks pretty uh,it's my best work yet!
PJ:  What was it? The first time we played uh, did uh Pewds: wait PJ: face tattoos, then we did..
Pewds: UUUUH NOO
Pewds: I hope this washes out
PJ: oh you got another one here.
Pewds: oh shit is this permanent for life?? right here.
Pewds: well PJ, it's always a pleasure isn't it PJ: oh yeah! I love it Pewds: thank you for coming over PJ: when are we doing this next?
*no  more suffering pls* * my hairs the most i can take* *pls*
Pewds: okay, well check out PJ (best youtsuber)
Pewds: I'll leave a link in the description
Pewds: thank- thank you, i guess... PJ: yeah no problem man! Anytime, anytime, Litterally anytime.
Pewds: I DUNNO WHY I CHALLENGE YOU TO A FUKIN GUESSING GAME. YOUR TOO GOOD AT THESE. PJ: Im too good at these.
Pewds: I WILL GET YOU ONE DAY PJ!
*and CUT*
*lmao PJ's face*
WATCH TILL THE END
Subtitles by - DemigodGirl and The Riddler
* just do it mannn*
*become apart of the fam*
*anyway, Sub to PJ today.*
* subtitled by people in description.*
*hope you have a good day*
*this took to long to subtitle*
*u wearin socks?*
*my back hurts*
*subscribe to jacksepticeye*
*And jack septiceye2 ;)) *
*topofthemornintoya;)))*
bye